hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to overwatch now I logged on
and apparently this group got a lot
bigger than I thought it was so I'm here
with Patrick static Tesh Wade and gar
and we're right over there
say hi guys along so don't mind about
them focus all on me because I'm
obviously the best and everything is
gonna be wonderful
I am admittedly not the best and I will
not set up any expectations for myself
because I just started playing but every
moment of my spare time has been
dedicated to playing this game right
guys exactly obviously I just want one
as one group you just mumble agreement
to whatever I said yes monument Cole
give me a source part please don't stop
mumbling those are words give me some
reserves so what I say when I say that
road hog grabbed me you all just murmur
murmur yeah high noon murmur oh no honey
of the roadway why aren't we finding a
group hey five all you had to do was
like making a mark agreement the game's
provides yeah bring it up the low level
greatness
I prefer fighting against low levels so
that's what we're not addicted to this
game did but I'm in the early stages
where I still have hope you gotta kiss
first yes he's gone you in quit it sigh
it's just slowly degrading I haven't
seen my youtube channel in a month what
does that mean gosh I hope you ever hear
all right so this one's an escort map we
got to get the thing to the thing you
know whatever it's just like you do
yeah it's personated yeah whatever don't
compare to DF do there is a widow does
up of the cliff in the back do we have a
with someone to show a look we're
scaring them they're all leaving they
shock ha ha the widow bang runs back is
not leaving but why hey I'm going for it
we just watch that Widowmaker
I got her I'm not gonna rock my car
I thought I was knocking her off ordered
tortured dirty turd for turtle just
nerding charlie
oh they got a sniper yes we know we're
aware of the sniper where is she got a
Hans on the roof where what are you
talking about there's the Hanzo on the
roof up there he had Hanzo on the roof
like / raysh I don't know what happened
to her
what are you so yeah I think whatever I
can't tell with that boob hanging out
you never know with these things
laughing cut out the milk not no job
forget you
man that Widowmaker doesn't want to come
out over the how my sides what didn't
you do ow who's doing that
ah there's a freaking someone behind now
out well go out this mg has given me Oh
hit him right in the face a pair
complete oh I'm out see you guys I was
gonna charge them but they died as I
charged so I just ended up leaving I've
got my hind you guys I knew no one cares
about your stupid moves what honey there
we go okay where are you mark are you
flying above oh no I had to take care of
this Widowmaker because she was mean
fine yeah there's a bunch of them
rounding the corner right about now
others may is there a tracer man oh god
ah damn it just missed the tracer the
other no no
I'm healing you will go die sir no die
yeah Oh Symmetra over there there we go
okay so far so good
did everyone die oh yeah I don't know
four of them before I did it was nari I
didn't see any of that happening
oh I'm sure if I did good you put that
Oh crunch out feels oh they're gonna
give it they just hold - Lucio disrupt
the beast or in the face I'm good for
yeah all right guys I'll happily for
heard on this video is to make sure that
I live at all times and look the best
possible and also each one of them shout
out my channel outro so there's a lot in
that not happening here and I'm very
disappointed in you guys market like the
best channel like ever like thank you
God doesn't give me more subs so good
looking and yeah it's gone but Sarah I
am got your justice just reigns from the
book from assured us because mom where
are you being hurtful look at the but oh
my god killed I was awesome I land
behind enemy lines and you've always let
me like that's might be part of your
problem yeah
what are you Sarah I'm a strong
independent woman who don't need you
guys to tell me what to do now get out
of the way so I can ultimate and rigor -
oh [ __ ] that tracer there is something
why was there no assistance on this huh
Oh guys we won you guys need to make me
look better
mark believe me we try there's just no
doing the hit of that blue hey I don't
know what I did what did I do
you were so good you gotta flip ok look
at the pill I hope that's all one kill
justice I'll see look good and even
though I'm not on this main menu here
with all of my other teammates on here
I'm probably good maybe maybe your
combinations don't common date each
other just wait until I pop up next I
did it myself
cuz no one else did
I want to say this it was a team effort
but you guys know it was and it was all
me with variously I don't think it would
have been able to get through that it
wasn't for you as as we wait for the
next game I'm just gonna replay my play
of the game to my viewers so they can
see how good I was I was taught I wish
there was a worst play of the game just
like the pathetic moments when I go up
in the air
rain justice and then die just just wait
for just yeah my favorite Toby all my
life away you guys I'm cool for horses
so highlight he's just smacking his fur
with a hammer guys don't worry I'll be
Farah okay cuz I didn't want model yet
roll down I was afraid someone wasn't
gonna be your you want six man Farah no
oh no I'm in time whenever you hear him
say hey Mark you want to just say no
yeah look and I look better if everyone
else looks like me it's not okay
what is Jail we're going to see crime
you just disrespected a well-known
youtuber you like that's that's not
allowed come on now there's a castle or
Casablanca what there's a Guantanamo for
bed but I just don't like I just so
brain salad is what happened you better
be careful or else you're gonna go to
Casablanca there's a honey noon man died
Oh Oh God kill him well this gossin
doing on High Noon it's just like that's
that's what he does oh wow monkey okay
monkey who the hell is monk is a ripper
behind us where he's inside he's trying
to destroy my turn
he destroyed my turn no he was very
successful
oh it's not a bad Pharaoh he's dead now
Matt Farah yes Barisan someone's trying
to beat me how I couldn't get him and I
didn't have him I had him I lost him you
guys let me get McCreight Yuma Creed
yourself the day you decided to be you
it was a sacrifice we were willing to
make thank you for your approval
Oh unwelcome on insta
I want to defend huh
no why would we do that got a guy on the
point I was being cool over on the side
Thank You Tesh for say nice I was trying
to keep Kevin off the point the monkey
house Kevin
monkey on the road my eggs oh man right
I'm sorry mark
they mean to take that killer for me why
didn't ya I was so close to getting him
that guy's dead
that guy's dead oh not dead yet but
gonna be dead it's an angry monkey got
ya guys out where's the monkey
okay Jesus hey help me tell me someone
help me do we not have heals
Oh God did [ __ ] me they're trying to set
up a teleporter symmetric behind double
team worsted Pam Anderson and Oh where's
my stop Wade stop stop there's a
family-friendly Channel come on where's
the help Jeff of mine we don't have a
healer I don't believe Oh healers are
for losers appears aha what was that
mark the dud
no no that was someone else I wouldn't
do that I wouldn't wanna Justice Court
thought of court got McCreary home base
you're far too talented and a beautiful
and I love you I know right
I attached the Metron left side
stairwell I'm coming for her I don't
know not really
bunkie almost dad [ __ ] we refinish
mesquite [ __ ] Val
ha where's Symetra she's off to the
right side
somehow she survived weights blast where
I don't see her you guys are lying whole
[ __ ] there she is
I thought ok monkey monkeys angry
I missed the monkey hi monkey got him
nice eliminated Kevin what's a monkey do
it better you shoot them from far away
uh wait if you can like none Oh
dragons dragon Duke it out
it's a Duke it out ow
Dorado coming up the left side he's
coming from behind intimidation us
cotton virtual addiction hey yeah we're
the greatest we're the best
I'm the greatest okay Wow
I gotta cheap that was that was good job
guys that was great work yeah gosh is it
turret work yeah oh yeah it was just my
toes she worked very hard for that Oh
Gil I Love You Man yes you got my vote
man I give all votes close to tell my
god another people like so much work
that highlight intro I'm gonna replay my
highlight from a previous play deported
or double Wow way to go mark
you different map different characters
different names no no
operating at the max
this the attack